Now, you used to see a lot of scientific
counsel within government. It was a
common thing during most of my lifespan:
Offices of Technology Assessment and so
forth. A lot of these guys cluttering up
the scene in government. They are a dying
breed. Because fundamentalists and
oligarchs both despise science. They
don't want it to have anything to do with them. Now
in this ancient standard of futurism, the
gold standard is Vannevar Bush, from the
1940s, who was one of the inventors of
the atomic bomb. A master engineer of the
Manhattan Project. He was also the father
of the American National Science
Foundation, because he wrote the
extremely important futurist text,
Science: The Endless Frontier. That screed
is probably the greatest work of
futurism ever put onto paper with a
typewriter. It's really an impressive
governmental document. And, you know, aimed at the head of state. So there's
still a problem with this. It's like: why
isn't science as respected as it was? And
I think the problem there is cultural. Because Americans, and especially
Californians, have a severe moral problem
with the idea that frontiers end. But
they're not endless. In fact, that gold
rushes just get old and die ugly;
they're not always young and pretty and
beautiful and glamorous and
forward-looking. They get old and cranky
and weird and obsessed
with themselves. And it kind of like
moved from, you know,
from savagery to barbarism without
civilization ever occurring. Savagery
barbarism, the decadence without without
a civilization, is a typical frontier
development. So you know to think that
the science is an endless frontier is
actually a bad paradigm, especially for a
futurist or a scientist. For instance,
paleontology is an important science,
which is about things that ended a long
time ago. And they just ended. They're not
gone; they're not gonna revive. You're not
gonna improve the trilobites, right?
But it's important to understand
what's going on in geologic time whether
there's anything to do with it or not.
And there are also many areas of
scientific investigation that are not
endless frontiers, they're dead ends. I mean
they're cul-de-sacs. They have to be
abandoned, such as phlogiston, you know? Or
the luminiferous ether, or spontaneous
generation, or even some aspects of
Newtonian physics.
They're not up to speed, and, you know, you
have to let those go. Scientific truth is
provisional; it's not permanent and
eternal. And science as a human
enterprise, I mean the actual business of
science, and how scientists are
recruited, promoted, how they quote one
another, that's a very time-bound, very
social kind of situation that changes
quite a lot as time as time goes on. So
if you think that atomic physics, or
maybe, the truth of atomic physics, the
scientific truth of atomic physics, is
somehow an eternal thing, then you have
to go all-out for nuclear power, or giant
gadgets like the superconducting
supercollider, which is unwise. That ambition is going to end in tears.
If you ask the government for 11 billion
dollars for a superb scientific
instrument that is not going to work
—it can't be built—
that is bad politics. It's poor
statesmanship. You're a scientific
futurist, but you gave bad advice. So if
you're a scientific futurist and you're
in the government pace layer, you can't
simply say to them, "I have some
inconvenient truth here, look at this
math." It won't work. You have to say, "I
have some inconvenient truth here, and I
can use it to win World War II with a
secret super weapon." That was the Vannevar
Bush method and that's what life
is like in the government pace layer
when things are really cracking right
along.